let's talk about the story we got from
project veritas that broke uh just a
moment ago we have this um from project
veritas i tweeted out breaking from
veritas twitter employee confirms bias
at twitter and that and i'll give you my
opinion uh seems i was right because
conservative because conservatives
tolerate leftist speech and leftists
won't tolerate the right twitter opts to
censor the right as balance so i'll play
a bit of this and you can hear from
weren't himself operating the capitals
more we were very social it's like we're
all like
communist
ideologically
uh it does not make sense like because
we're actually censoring the rights
so if everyone on the right wing will be
like bro it's okay to say just gotta
tolerate it
the left will be like no i'm not gonna
tolerate it
i need a
sensor
or else i'm not gonna be impactful so it
does sound right
it's true
i don't know if the two parties can
truly coexist on one platform what do
your colleagues say about like
they hate it oh my god i'm at least like
okay with it but some of my colleagues
are like super
left left
so i'll pause it there i think we all
know the stories about the political
meanings of people at twitter's
stance if elon gets hired they're like
we're out but for me when i saw this
what i found interesting was uh what
i've said before is
it's a business decision you got to take
a look at it from twitter's perspective
people like ben shapiro are memed for
saying debate me right they the right
wants to own the libs they want to be on
twitter they want to argue with liberals
so they like seeing these tweets libs of
tick tock is a really good example libs
of tic tac reposts the things the left
says like see hey look at this
on the left however they're the ones
that are flagging they're the ones
saying these people should be banned uh
you mentioned earlier that uh some of
these people had violated the rules and
that they had been suspended yeah sure
they could they could come back
so my point uh you know a couple weeks
ago was if twitter is confronted with
this from a business perspective they're
going to say the right doesn't care if
the left is saying things as much the
left does care if the right is saying
things so purely from a business
perspective we'll ban as many on the
right as we can without disrupting as
many users as possible and then we don't
got to ban the left because the right's
not going to do anything about it anyway
well i mean twitter has a very clear
well first of all i just want to say
that libs of tick tock there's a little
bit more than just reposting uh what
leftists say on tick tock we could get
into that maybe in a little bit but uh
on this topic um
you know uh
twitter has a pretty clear set of rules
and guidelines on their website
and uh it seems like uh
maybe just right accounts break those
policies more so than left-wing accounts
i know plenty of people who got banned
or suspended from twitter for just
literally saying like uh you know [ __ ]
you or uh you know
you know something like that and they
get the you know this is not uh part of
the twitter policy you're suspended for
you know people who got spent not even
just to delete the tweet and come back
and people who got spend it outright had
to start new accounts for something like
that uh there's you know from there with
learn to code yes so they were the
editor in chief of the daily caller was
commenting on on on the phenomenon and
got suspended for it so there were there
were tons of people and i think this may
be what we're seeing come back with the
the big surge and right-wing users at
least partly we also have to be careful
with this video here uh project veritas
has a uh a long history of
uh disseminating edited footage well i
mean everybody posts edited footage no i
mean edited footage that com i mean they
got sued by uh people who lost their job
uh there probably his bit you know james
acorn when acorn went out when a horse
closed down because james o'keefe
released that pimp video if you recall
that yeah uh he got sued and he lost
because there was more video to it and
everything he said that this woman
didn't you know didn't do she actually
went ahead and did she he had to pay her
he had to pay i think he settled that i
don't think he lost but you could call
it a loss in terms of if you settle well
has he has he lost anything since he
formed project veritas um
maybe we have to check the answer is no
he hasn't alright maybe he hasn't and so
uh so you know like we've had james on
the show we talked him about it he said
settling was the biggest mistake he made
because they weren't wrong but i want to
put words in his mouth because i can't
speak to to this this was uh before he
formed veritas since veritas has been
around they've not lost i'm pretty sure
they've not lost a single lawsuit in
fact they've won over and over and over
again
yeah and there's a whole wall of all the
news organizations who have backed down
and rescinded everything so i'm pretty
sure he's not lost anything yeah and i
that that lawsuit was not necessarily
just about them claiming they were
misrepresented a lot of it had to do
with california's two-party consent laws
with respect to recording somebody was
that it yeah california's two-party
consent look i'm i'm not um uh i think
my issue with the veritas stuff and the
arguments against him uh easily
exemplified by
i think it was channel 4 in the uk did
the exact same thing veritas does and it
was just heaps of praise all across the
media a deceptive like they they lie to
the targets they go in and they say like
here's who we are and it's not true and
then they secretly record them and then
they publish it on the news and it was
praised by all the big mainstream
publications that's exactly what veritas
does so if you do undercover reporting
then i mean i don't see what the issue
is in this settlement james o'keefe
claimed he was unaware that uh the woman
who was suing him uh literally did
everything that he claimed that she
didn't she called the police the second
he came in and he
she warned uh them about what was going
on and what she was experiencing and i
mean that was the that was the main when
this happened this was in uh 2013. and
was that project veritas or james
o'keefe uh i guess it was james o'keefe
i mean james o'keefe is project veritas
have you uh so look let's let's just say
uh
james o'keefe ten years ago i mean he
also he did it also he also nobody also
did that thing where that was there was
the um
that um person who was dropping off uh
ballots in um i think it was uh
minnesota minnesota yeah and the person
came out and said that he completely
distorted that he said they're on video
doing it like
no but that's but that's legal that's
okay to do what he was doing no it's not
it is you could drop off ballots that's
what happened man we got to pull up all
the sources uh yeah yeah
he had a car full of ballots and said he
was what did he say he was getting paid
to drop him off i mean that's that's
illegal
well let's let me look it up so yeah
yeah because you said that so so but
i'll put it this way i'll let let's
let's um
uh
we'll pull that up because i want to
make sure we have that we have it all
correct and everything i know that there
were there were accusations against uh
james over that one but my issue is just
like
how many stories has project veritas put
out how many how many real substantive
issues have people criticized him over
and then i'll say
first of all i'll put it this way
i'm pretty sure that was illegal because
we covered that extensively and we did
we went through all the laws and stuff
we can you know i don't know if sheamus
wants to look it up you can look it up
too and we'll make sure we get the facts
right but uh man
i don't understand why
all of this is directed at a handful of
stories veritas does when you have every
other day fake news coming out of the
washington post out of the new york
times out of cnn huge stories too there
were years long spans of lies and
manipulations some that resulted in
major lawsuits too like you know we
still use cnn the washington post and
the new york times despite the covington
kids lawsuits that they're all being
stood over and losing because we
recognize that news organizations get
things wrong unless there's evidence to
suggest something was not correct about
it i don't understand why
we would not just hold the scrutiny of
any organization uh oh absolutely that
includes yeah everything's media yeah so
when you know cnn or the new york times
can come out and say sources say
or people familiar with trump's thinking
have confirmed i'm just like yo the news
the news like mainstream press rolls
with those and veritas published a video
now by all means you can say the video
is deceptively edited if you don't
believe it's true
but
new york times doesn't even put out who
their sources are at the time well i
mean that's basic journalism you could
not trust corporate media if you would
like so what if they're but they're
surely they're surely uh well respected
specific reporters and journalists who
have a track record of good work what if
james o'keefe instead of revealing the
video just said we have a source within
twitter who has said this thing well
james o'keefe is a known liar based on
what we've previously heard about the
settlements and stuff so i mean um you
better be hold on i got i got to tell
you uh
back that up
i mean he paid a settlement a hundred
thousand dollars this woman and he
admitted that he
lied about what she said on the video
as long as you're saying that that's
true and you're willing to stand behind
it i mean like he said it he said it i'm
just saying settlement he said it in his
settlement i'm just saying that because
james has basically sued every single
person who has accused him and he's won
every single case i mean if he wants to
dispute the fact that he paid this woman
a hundred thousand dollars because he
said that he claimed that you know she
didn't call the police when he came in
with his pimp suit claiming what he
claimed um and she did and he said he
didn't know but
she he put the video out didn't ask her
i guess afterwards look i can you know i
can i can
we can say yes like it was wrong james
did a bad thing but i mean i mean he how
does that discredit the story what story
the the twitter story all i'm saying is
we don't know the whole the whole uh
conversation that went on there i agree
with that for sure um
so we have to go by what it's also it's
also like honestly a very like low bore
i mean so the the the um the accusation
is that what that leftists won't
tolerate the right i mean well that's
one of them okay but i mean they're just
they're just basically what are they
doing they're reporting a tweet for
something that this right-winger said
that would either a
not break twitter policies so there
would be no punishment let's let's talk
about the word policy there would then
be
misgendering policies regenerating
policy yep that's swedish policy yeah
yeah yeah absolutely and it's it's
biased against conservatives how is it
biased against conservatives
conservatives don't agree with the
concept of misgendering i mean
not a single one right i mean it's basic
respect if you ask me it doesn't matter
if i'm not i'm i'm not if you ask you're
coming from a left-wing perspective sure
but it's not i'm not making a moral
statement i'm saying conservatives don't
agree with the concept of misgendering
right that's a fact i mean
maybe there are conservatives that don't
i mean i do agree well but i mean do you
think conservatives agree with the
concept of misgendering i mean vast
majority yeah sure you think they they
agree that misgendering is a thing
no no they agree that they should have
the right to misgender someone right
they don't believe it exists you you
view it as they think they should be
allowed to but conservatives don't think
it's a thing
right so you've got you've got how many
with 74 million trump voters
i'd say the overall majority are like
either don't know what it even means or
if you look at the staunch conservatives
would outright say well we have to we
have to be very specific here about i'm
all for someone learning and
understanding and using the wrong
language i mean i know plenty of people
on the left i do myself sometimes i use
the wrong pronoun or whatever for
someone who you know does not identify
as that gender and if someone's coming
at it in good faith and not meaning to
you know to harm somebody or be you know
i don't want to deviate too much i mean
i mean
i mean the issue you brought up that
there's conservatives who don't even
know that's a thing now if one of those
conservatives does that thing on twitter
and then someone's just like hey you're
misgendering me and then they're just
like oh i'm sorry or just we're just
dude i mean
people say dude all the time and zooby
got banned for it he got a suspension
for saying okay dude well
in what context did he say i mean
zoopy's not someone who doesn't know
what misgendering is he was clearly
wondering
here's the point here's the point you're
making moral statement i'm making more
i'm not making a moral statement we know
conservatives don't agree we know the
left does twitter has a policy that the
left agrees with the right doesn't
therefore twitter has a policy bias
against the right that's that's that's
that's a a simple fact statement i mean
if you're some if you're coming from if
you're coming from the position that um
if you don't agree that this is the
thing i mean well like
twitter is saying it's a thing like it's
their platform they're saying this is
the thing
you're misunderstanding how am i
misunderstanding it i'm not making a
moral statement okay i'm not saying
twitter is right or wrong
twitter is well within its rights to
have whatever rules it wants sure
conservatives disagree with the concept
uh uh progressives
agree with the policy twitter's rules
suit the view of the left and not the
right
that's simply true twitter's deciding to
make those rules i mean absolutely we
agree on that yeah okay so if
conservatives don't agree with those
rules twitter's rule set is biased
against the conservative worldview i
mean there's all sorts of rules i don't
agree with too but it doesn't mean
they're biased against my worldview this
is just what they do i mean
the misgendering thing is is clearly cut
obviously if we can if we want to
nitpick you can talk about the the
various right-wing factions i mean if
you don't if you don't agree that trans
people exist when they clearly do then i
don't know what to tell you i don't know
who said that on the right yeah i mean
i'm on the right look i i don't believe
in the concept of transgenderism uh i
don't believe there's a difference
between gender and sex
and i would say that tim is making a
descriptive statement he's not saying
that it's good or bad that twitter has
this specific policy he's just saying
that on the issue of transgenderism
twitter has clearly taken aside and
their side is that a person's gender
identity is a concept which supersedes
their biological identity that's a
decision they made as a platform which
is a politically biased decision i mean
they're basically saying trans people
exist though because if you take that
away then what is i mean what are you i
don't know i'm not quite i mean i know
what you're arguing but you're basically
saying it's biased against conservatives
to admit that trans people exist by
twitter that's not what they're doing
yeah
they're not saying people suggest
they're saying you are forced to
acknowledge that you believe this
identity is their identity even if you
don't agree with that then or else
you're not on the platform yeah because
that's what the misgendering policy is
they're not even saying that they're
saying you have to use this language or
we will ban you okay conservatives say
i do not believe in the use of that
language and it's overt i mean it i
would say
99 out of 100 conservatives would be
like i'm not going to use preferred
pronouns
if twitter's rules are in line with your
worldview or a progressive worldview
they're biased against conservatives i
don't think we're arguing i think we
agree on that i mean i i don't think
it's biased against conservatives be
quite honest but we could go in circles
on this or we could just you know it's
up to you so you think conservatives
are
you're not making you're not making
sense man i mean what do you mean if you
basically tell someone we know
conservatives like don't use the concept
of misgendering we we know conservatives
will call a trans woman he right yes
therefore twitter's rules do not
are are are not fitting what
conservatives do and think on a daily
basis
i mean
it is over it is like it's one plus one
equals two it's like just right there in
front of you i mean you could argue that
about anything though like what i mean
like what like you can't say the n word
on twitter and and do conservatives want
to say the answer yeah
oh please
they do
see not all conservatives but they're
the sub section of twitter that does
want to is certainly on the right there
are people who like using bad words on
the right there are people who like
using bad words on the left if you wanna
like we're not gonna i'm not gonna make
a blanket statement that every leftist
wants to advocate for antifa going and
killing people but they're certainly
antifa that go around advocating for
killing people right
how many people have advocated for
killing libs of tick tock a large amount
we can pull up tweets how many people
have advocated for
serious physical harm to andy no i'm not
going to sit here and say everyone on
the left wants to violently harm you
know andy you know there are people who
did it there are good and bad people the
issue is if you go to some of the most
prominent conservatives like ben shapiro
he will say i do not use preferred
pronouns sure he's got one of the top
podcasts in the world and twitter's
rules
conflict with one of the biggest
possibilities you don't you don't
you don't have to use someone's pronouns
at all though i mean you could easily
talk about that individual by their name
yeah i mean but i might make like i said
i'm not making a moral statement if ben
shapiro wants to say he he's told he
can't or he'll be banned well i mean
that's just twitter's rules twitter's
right twitter's rules fit the leftist
worldview well i mean if a if a
leftwinger also wants to do that then
they can't either right but the left
tends to agree with that perspective
it's the leftist worldview or it's a
component i mean yes left people agree
that trans people exist i mean i arguing
they don't exist why do you keep saying
that because if you're not gonna if
you're not gonna basically uh
acknowledge someone's gender identity
then you're saying they're not trans
people don't exist but what does that
mean trans people don't exist i mean
that someone's not trans what do you
mean what
so
sheamus can argue what do you say
transgenderism doesn't exist or what
yeah i don't believe gender and sex are
i don't believe like in the concept of
gender it was developed the coin was f
that the term was first coined by dr
john money who was like a pedophile and
sex pervert who abused children and
created this idea that we can make um
this this false distinguishing between a
person's actual biological sex and the
sex they should be treated as within
society i don't think it's a legitimate
concept i believe and i agree that there
are people
who struggle with their identity i think
there are people who are deeply confused
about their sexual identity i do not
believe a man can ever become a woman or
that a woman can ever become a man i
don't yeah
that's what you believe all right but i
mean i don't know the information that
you just said in terms of i can look it
up but um
uh you know people do suffer from gender
disorders yeah that's a real that's a
right that's a real thing absolutely and
everybody agrees those people exist yes
so why do you keep saying trans people
don't exist because
you're saying
that gender dysphoria they really exist
yeah that's real things
but you're saying that the actual
outcome what they're looking to do to
actually uh treat their gender dysphoria
it's not a real thing well no no no no
no yes that's yes that's trans trans
people exist and will
and i've met trump supporting uh trans
women for sure and and hackers and
leftists and right-wingers of course
they exist of course gender is real
they're trans women they have preferred
pronouns and
whether or not you compel someone to use
those words has nothing to do with
saying they exist or not
if you refuse to use anyone's pronouns
or just refuse to even call them by
their name i mean i don't just i mean i
don't know what to say to you i mean i
mean if i called you floorbo would that
be denying your existence if i if you
call me flirbo yeah if i'm if i use the
pronoun for you that wasn't your
preferred pronoun am i denying your
existence i mean personally it wouldn't
bother me but that's just me am i
denying your existence are you denying
my existence i mean people could argue
disrespectful for sure but am i denying
your existence well because trans people
don't
uh acknowledge that they have that their
their you know their birth name or given
name is what they you know that's not
them
do you i i don't know i don't know what
to say i mean you're saying they're
claiming trans people don't exist that's
like a buzz phrase with no meaning
you've conveyed no idea to anyone what
are you talking about what idea are you
trying to convey when you say
conservatives say trans people don't
exist what is that supposed to mean you
know what that's supposed to mean if
you're yeah
let's go let's go let's go back to the
original thing that you were talking
about twitter's policy and you're saying
it's purposefully um
okay it's biased no moral statement sure
it is a rule set that the world the left
agrees through the right doesn't and
therefore is biased against the
conservative worldview okay and if
twitter did not have that policy then it
would be biased against trans people no
it wouldn't be well no it would be
unbiased right if twitter had a policy
which said
um
if twitter had no policy on what
pronouns you could use for someone that
would not be biased that would just be
like the lack of a policy altogether
yeah the left would lack lack of policy
could be biased no no no
the inversion would be twitter saying
you are not allowed to use preferred
pronouns right
so once the conservatives don't want to
refer to trans women by she her right
okay they could just not refer to trans
women that way so but you'll get banned
on twitter just
you do not have to go after a trans
person so here's my point if you can
exist on twitter without attacking a
trans person if twitter were calling
them but again this is this is a
left-wing framing that it's attacking
someone to not use the pronouns that
affirm this idea that there's something
that they're not
the point the point is the rules it's if
i started calling you she for example
that would be completely incorrect
because i'm not a woman i'm a man i've
been a man my whole life and even if i
decided to identify as a woman i still
would not become a woman but i would
have thought
if but if you did though out of the
common respect to refer to you by your
gender identity so i i absolutely
believe that you are coming at this from
a place of respect but i don't think
it's respectful to indulge something
that's not well hold on hold on hold on
we're deviating way too far the point is
twitter's rules overtly biased if
twitter removed the rule there would be
no bias because there's no rule
if twitter created a rule that said
trans people are not allowed to use
preferred pronouns that would be biased
in favor of conservatives
if twitter
also made a rule that said that you know
you can now use the n word who do you
think that affects who's that biased
against that's biased against people who
uh black people yes right yes but is
there a policy saying you're a like the
the issue
the issue is
twitter uh negative rights positive
rights uh et cetera et cetera twitter is
saying here is a list of things you
can't do and it tends to be things
conservatives do right okay i'm sorry
that conservatives do things that tend
to disrespect people i mean that's
that's i'm not making a moral judgment
if you want to say they're they're
disrespecting people i don't care i'm
simply saying twitter's rule set favor
is the leftist approach all right and i
disagree but that's that that's that's
impossible i'm not making i'm not making
an opinion statement i'm making a fact
statement i just don't agree i mean we
know from just how these social media
platforms just we could take twitter
specifically how they work
they tend to the algorithm tends to um
write uh uh
platform content on the right all the
time well they platform everybody all
the time no you get you they recommend
right-wing content more often than not
that's 100 who does
uh any social media platform
facebook
um twitter
you are wrong uh let me let me try the
tube's another one yeah let me uh let me
let me try and pull up the uh
see if i can find the article you know
one of the challenges with doing these
like we sit down and we talk about is
we're always trying to you know figure
out where we saw something and all that
stuff
so let me see if i can uh
find this oh do you want me to buy this
muckrack is trying to sell me the
article
uh let me see if i can try and find this
article
it's by a researcher named mark ledwich
twitter algorithm's bias toward
right-wing content says who twitter's
own research and what and what did they
say and why did they say uh twitter is
publicly sharing research findings today
this is from protocol uh that show that
the platform's algorithms amplify tweets
from right-wing politicians and content
from right-wing news outlets more than
people and content from the political
left
uh
there you go
i'm trying to pull up this mark ledwich
thing
so i see this from the washington post
october 22nd 2021 twitter algorithms
amplify conservative content more than
that of the political left researchers
fine who are the researchers
an internal evaluation of twitter's
recommendation algorithms concluded that
they amplify right-leaning political
content more than left-leaning content
company researchers announced thursday
undercutting allegations by many
conservatives who contend they are being
censored on the platform now that
statement is is just confusing and
factually incorrect twitter can promote
conservatives but doesn't mean you know
you get a bomber of this elon musk why
don't you ask him to uh find out more
information about this nothing agreed
if conservatives are complaining about
being censored the fact that twitter
promotes some conservatives doesn't mean
conservatives aren't being censored the
fact that twitter would promote more
conservatives doesn't mean some
conservatives aren't being censored so
washington post point
but uh
we'd have to
the research and months of the making
part of twitter's promise to evaluate
evaluate the underpinnings blah blah
blah i'm trying to see what the meat of
what they're actually saying is and it
don't seem it doesn't seem to be in the
article they said they analyzed millions
of 2020 tweets by elected officials in
seven countries canada france germany uh
okay so it's not an american thing as
well as post that oh come on
all right i can debunk this in two
seconds for you okay go ahead
all right from the new york times what
happens to america's political center of
gravity as you can see the right-leaning
uh platforms the right-leaning political
parties in europe are to the left of the
republican party so when you say twitter
is amplifying right-wing content it's
like okay okay in america yes or no the
answer is no because the parties that
were getting amplified european parties
are to the left of the republican party
i mean so you so it's to the right of
you that's a fair point it's to the left
of the american uh conservative well
that's a major statement that you have
to probably check with uh you know the
researchers who put together this study
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you